oh my god it's the [ __ ] fly this
[ __ ] [ __ ] Oh what is going on YouTube
now you know what time it is
it's article time with David so Uncle
Tom
okay that's not that stick is it
somebody make me an intro song something
bubbly in life oh but you guys submitted
it so we're gonna talk about it so if
you haven't heard of this one this one
the doozy now usually when we talk about
the news on this channel it's usually
about some negative [ __ ] but this time
it's gonna be ha ha I'll tell an armless
woman named Jessica Cox flies a plane
for the first time with her feet that's
pretty [ __ ] amazing
but now here's the thing I enjoy
watching positive news it makes me
believe that not everybody's motive in
life is to stick their dick in something
or stick a dick in something but but the
one thing I hate about this type of news
is that it makes me feel so bad about us
oh this woman is absolutely amazing you
just make you realize how much of a lazy
piece of [ __ ] I have cuz if you think
about it she has no hands and it
accomplished something that most of us
can't do in our lifetime
in all honesty every time you feel like
you can't do something you should have a
picture of this woman on your wall
giving you the middle finger it would a
toe and even worse is if you have an
Asian pear don't you ever show that this
article cuz you will never be able to
complain ever again dad my stomach hurts
that girl had no arm but she dumped him
that I hit by a car she doesn't care I'm
[ __ ] dying did girl never complain
[ __ ] on him the nut [ __ ] you guys
already know if you're an Asian kid and
you have a successful friend you never
bring them home why you ask because it's
always a medium of comparison for your
parents y'all ready to doctor you are
crown know that I'm a comedian oh oh
professional clown well you don't you
don't make me cry your parents ever say
[ __ ] to you they make you tear up on the
spot I swear it wasn't gonna do this
that's my [ __ ] when I cry I turn to
assist in your girl hey but you know to
me people like Jessica Cox is a perfect
example of human perseverance if you put
your mind to something tell me what the
[ __ ] in this world I cannot do well she
did write the article that she can't
really do her hair but you know that's
different
did she 5 playing go [ __ ] this is a
woman who took her disability that
everybody else thought in their eyes
that she refused to accept this is a
woman who took that
our jelly saga said [ __ ] it to Quadra
she said naturally people saw me not
having an arm as a limiting factor but I
was there to prove them wrong that right
there gets me right here how many of you
out at the moment you are faced with
something that tries to tear you down
you let it a lot of you guys out there
need to learn how to not take your
failures as a permanent loss but instead
take that experience and then make
something better from it y'all be the
are Kelly that [ __ ] who's a show me
your face
I'm gonna piss on it nope not now
Jessica cops I don't really know you but
what I think you're trying to tell our
crowd right now is that life sometimes
is a cross I [ __ ] of a fish of a trauma
but a dynamite in that [ __ ] and that's
probably not what you meant but it's
something a lot of lines of blood
[ __ ] failures but thanks for setting
in this article I wanted to share this
with you guys because I wanted to spread
the positive message so Thank You
Jessica once again for taking away every
Korea kids right to complain [ __ ] you
did